welcome to another episode of the
Streamy award winning podcast not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig this is
a very exciting day and I can't believe
it's taken this long to have this
amazing content creator generally funny
human and just all-around Dave Matthews
Band's number one fan
Jack's films Jack Douglas is with us
today on this episode of nacho deep and
we really dive into the essence of of
his love for Dave Matthews Band and and
also you know he's got some opinions
about um the beef with PewDiePie
it gets pretty juicy so enjoy this
episode of not too deep with jacksFilms
not too deep is brought to you by
Squarespace turn your great idea into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're showcasing your
work or selling products of any kind
with beautiful templates and the ability
to customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but if you do get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you are ready to
lunch use the offer code grace grac e to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain this is exciting I
can't believe it's taken this long I
can't either this has been a long time
coming we've just been talking for
months right okay I know this is the new
thing in 2019 that I've decided to start
opening the podcast with this question
what's your deal oh boy that's a that's
a very specific focused targeted
question doing
I'm a headless chicken grace I'm just
running around and couldn't be more
accurate you know I mean aren't we all
yeah we all know we were talking about
this a little bit before how long have
you been now making videos for its
you're in double digit years wise well
into 13 damn years 13 yeah starting to
slowly [ __ ] yeah dude I know it's so you
have this very interesting trajectory to
me because I met you on the set of my
music with the fine brothers absolutely
and you had already been sort of a
veteran
even though that was like 2009-10
something like that that was I want to
say 2011 I'm sure they'll fact check
that immediately and then it felt like
you've been doing it forever and then
all of a sudden it was like people were
sleeping on your channel and then I turn
around and you're just like that one of
the number-one youtubers all the sudden
but I was like he's been doing this way
longer than I think people know or give
him credit for dates I'm the one of
those og old man youtubers I got the
fine if I limit I got the fine brothers
to thank for that big push by the way
they did teens react to Jack's films
back in 2012 I think and that pushed me
over the edge that and that that's what
happened that I mean yeah that does that
does change things it really does it
really does so god bless them you know
so how do you I mean you do comedy you
do parody and I think you are just a
professional troll machine sure it is
when did you because I feel like it was
a pivot and what you decided this is the
kind of content that's working and that
I'm gonna do like what was that
I'll tell you exactly when I can
pinpoint it to college a January 2009
okay now before that it was sometime in
2008 so I made like sketches and stuff
they never took off go away so there's
only two years into my channel I'm like
a sophomore in college or whatever and I
was bored one day I watched Apple was
releasing a new product okay and there
were rumors of like a super thin laptop
and I'm like I'm reading all the tech
blogs what else are you enjoyed like me
and I was so pumped for this product and
so I watched the whole launch the
announcement and it was really
underwhelming to me at least I was like
oh that's [ __ ] it yeah yeah dragon
and so I was like you know what [ __ ] it
I'm gonna make fun of it like so I just
made like a minute long fake commercial
okay mocking like I used their little
jingle like whatever song they used for
their commercial but I just stubbed in
my voice like the new MacBook Air blah
blah blah and that parody for whatever
reason took off well that was like my
first viral video back in 2008
and people really I don't like took a
liking to it so much so that I realized
maybe I could be the parody guy mm-hmm
and then I kept doing stuff like that
just like the the Snuggie I made fun of
that and this and that and people kind
of took me to be the carrot II the
parody guy okay but then you started
doing your grammar sucks which for
people that don't know how would you
explain that your grammar sucks is
really just an excuse to make fun of
people online who can't spell perfect
and I get mad when I first thought it
was so mad that I didn't think of that
idea I was like this is really [ __ ]
good well you bet
you've been in at least two of them at
least your grammar sucks 40 and 100 I'm
sure there's something else I'm
forgetting but I'm only like a hundred
sixteen or so only okay well I used to
crank him out every week now I do like
one or two a year just cuz I got tired
of it it's crazy but it's pure and
perfect thank you I don't know about
either of those things but it's it was
really fun to do for a while but now
it's kind of I do it less frequently
because it's at the point where it's
like well I don't know what else I've
done it all when it comes to making fun
of grammar there only there are only so
many times yeah we can make fun of
someone for typing raper instead of
rapper you know what it means like it's
it's it's run the gamut like it's run
its course
so it's tougher to make new episodes of
that series because it's like how many
times can you make fun of someone for
writing the wrong form of there so it
has to be for you at some point too cuz
I'm burnt out and this is not fun for me
anymore
absolutely but you do a great job of
using audience participation really well
and like in a celebratory way but also a
completely mocking way it's a lot of
both you know like my viewers they're
all really sarcastic because that's kind
of like my sense of humor it's sort of
dry sarcastic sassy yeah they also we
all kind of celebrate that so a lot of
my viewers write very sassy sarcastic
comments so you're exactly right so it's
like a lot of audience interaction with
my with the series yesterday I asked you
series but of course there's a lot of
mocking on both sides too late make fun
of me I make fun of them it's beautiful
nobody gets hurt
do you have because you have
you're breeding this sense of sarcasm
do you have weird real-life fan
interactions like do people come up and
say things or approach you in any way
that's like they think it's going to be
funny but it just misses the mark
I can think of only one IRL example that
happens last year I thought about this
since I was coming out of the gym just
waiting for my uber back home and this
guy comes up to me and he's like hey
he's like you look older in person and
I'm very taking it back and I go what
and he says is that not as that isn't
that one of your catchphrases oh my god
no that's not me dude I think he got a
confused he had seen me on the h3
podcast gotcha I gotcha it recognized me
from that uh-huh so maybe that was like
an Ethan joke but I'm not but I'm not
sure so I didn't and he like I felt he
felt bad like he immediately realized
the error of what he had just done it is
really [ __ ] funny like in hindsight
like humor like imagines a guy going up
to you and going like hey you look older
like you might have been getting
directly hit on and didn't realize until
he struck out
well my gaydar sucks so that make it
very possible very very I've always had
willfully bad gaydar what's the like
what's the core audience like who's your
demo well it's um it here's a cool thing
it's not heavily guys or girls it's kind
of split down the middle which I'm happy
about yeah yeah cuz I try not to skewer
towards like a totally dude audience
like I don't really dude dude bro comedy
so that's kind of nice yeah age-wise
I shoot for like our age like I shoot
for 18 to 35 like I kind of like that's
my target demo in my head okay the
reality is a little younger it's like 13
to 21 or something
everyone's watching up everyone's
looking right yeah so I mean I try to do
stuff that I think guys my age would
find funny ya know could you talk a lot
about gaming are you like an actual
gamer
they're a little bit a little bit yeah I
dabble and I'm more of a council guy
than a PC guy okay I never got making a
PC gaming [ __ ] suck at fortnight so
like every time I play I die instantly
it's really fun but um I'm more of like
a like I like smash brothers like the
Mario games games that kind of stuff and
a little bit of PlayStation but you know
I'm not like a hardcore gamer sure I
make fun of hardcore gamer but I do
dabble on gaming you dabble you dip your
toe in sure do okay you're married to a
beautiful wonderful woman yeah
supposedly according to the internet
Aaron is also a Taylor Swift obsessed
fan yes she is she does love oh yes I
also am a Taylor Swift fan
oh let's dive in have you had to learn
the ways of Taylor Swift because of your
wife now I so we've been to one concert
yeah so far how was that experience for
you it was actually fine it was a lot of
fun great it's on a grid and she sings
all the hits you know what I'm saying
yeah she gives she doesn't give us an
indie [ __ ] new just the hits and that
was a lot of fun honestly I got I got
nothing against Taylor I'm not like I
keep using this like word this phrase
dude bro I'm not too much of a dude bro
to be above liking her pop stuff mm-hmm
you know so but yeah she Aaron loves her
stuff mm-hmm she also she also loves
Hamilton so like when she comes home
from work she'll just scream Hamilton
particularly you couldn't have sounded
more like a husband comes home from work
she just screams oh yeah I mean I'm
curious about that because as a person
that does comedy online I'm always
fascinated about like toeing the line of
how much of my personal life I showcase
like in social media or in video it's
like where do you make like a conscious
effort to like draw the line or you just
kind of like this is my life it is what
it is I'll put out whatever I want and
there are some things I'm like a tiny
bit more secretive about sure I'm not
terribly worried about that just because
the videos I make are really vlog style
right so there's not too much to really
I mean like when I make my videos
they're all sketches or
there are these guys videos or whenever
they're not too much like I'd say in the
life right right if I did that then yeah
I'd be a bit more you know conservative
yeah exactly but I I don't that's I'm
not too worried because that's not the
kind of stuff I make like when I tweet
is just like dumb jokes and [ __ ] yeah do
you guys have you ever had to have a
conversation where it's like this is for
her sake like I don't want to be in this
video I don't want to be mentioned in
this so a little bit yeah and I hesitate
because every video we filmed together
so and there's another series I do
called Jack asked and it's like mine it
started off as a mock Q&A shows I got a
bit more real yeah that's the with it
the hit a twinge of that sassiness mhm
so we had a tradition where like every
ten episodes Aaron would join me and we
would take questions from our viewers
for the both of us right and largely for
Aaron because she is way funnier than I
am
and people know that too like the real
quick to point that out
thanks guys so but before we film every
single time and we've done like nine ten
of these and every single time Aaron's
like give me some wine I really don't
work fine and everything here's a funny
thing too so we film for like an hour
sometimes two hours yeah Wow well just
enough so that like we have enough
material but you can get rid of stuff if
it's like I don't know about that part
yeah exactly so we filmed for two hours
and it's only like a 10 maybe 15 minute
long video total but every time after we
film she always turns to me and says I
don't think that was funny really yeah
and it's always and I always tell her
like honey you were incredible and then
and and and people end up loving it like
it turns out being it turns out being
great because of her cuz when you guys
met first of all how did you guys meet
each other okay so there are two stories
in story yeah yeah yeah the the short
story is we met at a bar in Philly I was
there visiting college friends for the
first time in Philly and I met her at a
bar and we just kind of hit it off okay
longer story longer story is that she
saw one of my videos from 2009 it was a
Snuggie parody back in 2009 and we had
friended each other on Facebook back
then back when Facebook
are more exclusive you know yeah and but
we just because we were friends on
Facebook he never talked we didn't know
the other person existed you just one of
those dumb like she friended a youtuber
cuz she thought that vid was funny I
accepted because why not and then we
never talked until three years later in
2012 I post a dumb thing on Facebook
it's like after Christmas before New
Year's and I post like my new year's
resolutions lose 10 pounds get a million
subscribers acquire girlfriends and you
know it's like tongue-in-cheek but it's
also like Erin on her end she sees this
she's getting over a breakup she sees
this and she sarcastically types she
responds or replies I'll be your
girlfriend oh my god inserts then oh so
I see this and I go what the like I
don't know who this person is great
we're somehow friends yeah I had totally
forgotten Oh both of us had forgotten
the other existence yeah so I check out
this girl's profile I stalk her a bit
and I'm like what the [ __ ] she's cute
she's way out of my league
am I being catfished being a fan I
thought I was being catfished and and
then I find out like oh she's from
Philly I'm going to Philly in like a few
days like it was actually the planets
align like it was actually like right by
Eve of me leaving for Philly yeah
so I message her and I'm like haha saw
you reply lull in Philly if you want to
meet up for drinks on Saturday and
that's how we really Wow
that's like the [ __ ] notebook right
beautiful story can I say the notebook
is so [ __ ] flawed and how they like
me he like literally hangs on a ferris
wheel unit and what does he do so so
Gosling uh-huh to get this girl's
affection there at like some carnival
she's on a ferris wheel that's what
girls do girls do with another guy her
boyfriend well I guess and he's hanging
on the ferris wheel and he says if you
don't go out with me I'm gonna kill
myself and drop that's a hundred look it
up right but it's [ __ ] true and I've
always liked that's a terrible if I get
a message
to send to people that's emotionally
abusive Wow and if a girl did that to
get a guy's attention
she'd be labeled crazy it would be a
Twitter highlight for sure oh but Aaron
wasn't involved in the digital world or
was she no no no no no she's not a she's
never been a youtuber okay you know it
very very different very different
worlds but she's had to learn to adapt
to this lifestyle no but she honest she
has adapted she adopted so [ __ ] quick
like she knows all the youtubers like
you know she she picked up on the
culture extremely quickly and she's
awesome in front of a camera she plays
she plays shy like no I don't want to do
this and then she kills it every single
time
oh that's sweet right that's modern
romance right there people sure is think
about that for a second okay now you
have to fur babies to fur yep sorry it
took me a second answered like Furby
Furby zip - yes we have um - white
fluffy dogs Klondike and Sunday
they look like cartoons it doesn't make
sense to me and I honestly thought you
had Photoshop I didn't realize you had -
I thought you were just photoshopping
like a cloned dog he's doing oh no he
has two dogs I wish I were that funny
it's so funny but they look like actual
goddamn cartoons they and they are Ken
what's their breed what do they call
their American Eskimos and they're
either toy breed or mini breed they're
like you know smaller than standard so
why that dog that type because and then
why another one of the same timeit's the
first one just like google image
searching dogs I mean that is them I've
been there
right it's either that or Zillow Assoc
was yep yep yep I prefer Trulia but you
know she she finds a picture of a phone
American Eskimo a mini a toy American
Eskimo riding a tricycle
[Laughter]
she was like done so we got climbing
give me that please that's so funny I
don't know how the second one to get the
first one and you realize that it's
pretty great then you got to get another
one it was yeah it was like she needs a
playmate do they get along with each
other actually do they play all the
[ __ ] oh that's cute as heck yeah yeah
it's honestly it's a tumbleweed of just
a white blur a tornado throughout like
they just wrassle and wrassle and it's
adorable
god bless i mean they're truly the
greatest joy that we have left in this
burning apocalypse that we're living
it's all we got
protect them at all cost on that very
light-hearted optimistic note we're
gonna take a quick more jacksFilms you
deep hum nutrition is all about making
you look and feel your best each
specific supplement packs a combo of
potent ingredients designed for specific
aims like clear skin boosted energy
fuller hair and it's backed by clinical
results hum focuses on preventing
concerns and long-term care repair not
damage control and covering up their
quote inside out approach to beauty goes
beyond a scare care regimen alone to
give you great results hums products are
sustainably sourced non-gmo and free of
soy gluten artificial colors and
preservatives plus lots of vegan options
try supplements like the daily cleanse
hair sweet hair growth gummies uber
energy and more if you aren't sure what
you need go to hummock nutrition comm
slash get underscore started to take a
quiz and get personalized
recommendations from hums team of
registered dieticians to make things
even easier hum offers a monthly vitamin
subscription that's affordable flexible
and convenient these guys are absolutely
wonderful and they make it easy to
understand the dietary restrictions or
nutrition's or whatever you might need
on a very simple level so go check them
out highly recommend go to humm
nutrition calm / get underscore started
for your personalized recommendations
and get 20% off your purchase with code
gray
that's omnitrition calm slash get
underscore started and code grace we're
back with jacksFilms how did you create
the name for your YouTube channel I was
I'll tell you how it was 2006 luckily
there were very very few youtubers yeah
and I wanted something vague and and
broad I didn't really know what I was
going to like I didn't see YouTube as a
viable way to make how did you stumble
onto YouTube because like my history is
that I took an editing class in college
and our professor had us all register
accounts so that we could share our work
with each other smart uh professor I
thought it was just like an internal
college website that we were all sharing
my first stuff on my youtube channel is
just projects from college oh that's
awesome
yeah it's embarrassingly sweet but yeah
so how did you find it I found it
through some of my friends in high
school
okay we're just uploading dumb like not
even pranks just like videos of them
clowning around outside outside our high
school in Maryland and they're just
uploaded it I really liked the name of
it YouTube it's like you to like like I
like that it's like my own TV channel
yeah remember when everyone created
accounts that's like shanedawsontv I'm
sure Jack's films was absolutely yeah
yeah but I wanted to keep it vague cuz I
didn't really know outside of comedy
what kind of stuff I'd be up short sure
and I was lucky enough because it was
2006 I'm lucky enough that I was able to
get a name as easy as Jack's films and
not like Jack films 8 8 4 7 9 3 you know
so that's why I couldn't do that today I
would have a hard [ __ ] time trying to
come up with a with an original channel
name - oh yeah it's impossible markets
over sounds right yeah just figure out a
different occupation absolutely that's
what I say burn it down
maximum capacity it's now a fire hazard
ok people ask you tons of questions I'm
sure what's one question you hate
getting asked and contrarily what's one
question no one's asked you that you
wish that you could answer oh that's a
tricky one ok let me tackle the first
one yeah first
I hate when people ears deal
so PewDiePie kind of created a
unintentional shitstorm yeah are you
guys genuine friends or genuine friend
okay okay yeah yeah we're not actually
mortal enemies got it however what
happened was in summer of 2017 mm-hmm
yeah I kind of vaguely vaguely know this
situation please explain it so in summer
of 2017 he jokingly made a video called
Lawai or he started a series called
Lawai wlw ia Y stands for last week I
asked you yeah and it was a very obvious
parody mm-hmm a loving parody of
yesterday I asked you my series yeah
which I had been doing at that point for
two years right and hundreds of episodes
and so I thought oh that's really cool
like the number one youtuber in the
world is making this loving parody of my
series like I was flattered yeah that
was really [ __ ] cool and people got
it his fans got it my viewers got it
like we all got it yeah and he kept
going for a while blah blah blah and
then it got even funnier because he had
a guy another youtuber Dave day bye Dave
it was a musician right his theme song
like a musical jingle and it was a total
copy of my original theme song for guy
but it was like but like we're all in on
the joke I loved I laughed out loud the
first time I saw it was like it was cute
and we all lived in this merry world
where like PewDiePie copied me and like
air quotes yeah I know if you can't see
that but I'm it was all a great joke
January of last year and 2018 mm-hmm he
uploads a video called like who copied
who or who stole who or something like
that
okay and the whole video was very
sarcastically blaming me for copying his
the why show even though the opposite is
true yeah but like he makes this whole
like a jet he's just like he point out
some tweet like joke tweets of mine his
expense and blah blah blah and even
pointed out like you stole my theme song
you know the track
uh-huh and so like I thought that was
the coolest damn thing it was like the
height it was like oh how cool is this
like he's still doing this and like
really and like I'm in the thumbnail and
blah blah blah unfortunately a lot of
his viewers did not get the joke they
thought like even though he was being
sarcastic they did not pick up on his
sarcasm yes and they did they attack you
for oh yes and they come out in droves
and I don't want to say like all
PewDiePie's fans are dumb but no but
they are they know mob mentality moment
and like if you have 60 melt like at the
time and 50 or 60 million subs a lot
like a portion of a giant fan base yeah
we'll be done that's just statistics
that's inevitable it's in my fan bases
and yours like that's just its
statistics so like any portion of sixty
million is a lot so much so that I had
to make a little joke video I actually
ended up making last year a your grammar
sucks video just based off on the
comments the hate comments I got yes
yeah so and just to point people out
like I had first off I had to explain
the joke and when you explain a joke
just deflates the all the comedy out of
it and it's so depressing
but anywho okay so this is a very long
answer to a short question to this day
yeah to this day I flash-forward a full
twelve months after all of this to this
day I still get genuine people who still
believe I stole from PewDiePie on
Twitter people are like why why'd you
[ __ ] still alive or like you know you
copied Lawai right or blah blah blah and
I know that they're genuine cuz they
don't follow like if I if I click on
their handle and they follow me I know
it's a joke right if they don't follow
me oh my god that's what I hate when
people it's not even a question
sometimes just like you just [ __ ]
copy pewds so but that's what I do
genuinely hate because it's like I
explained this a year oh it was it was
this cute little joke that exploded
because sarcasm is hard yeah what I okay
so that's what I hate what I wish makes
sense and I feel like it's never gonna
go away completely because the internet
is for
ever DNR it's written in ink yeah it's
written in ink so it doesn't matter I I
could make this video every week and
people would still you know but you are
you were and still are a genuine fan of
PewDiePie yeah yeah I am because like
he's he's smart I mean like he's a
maniac he's I'm Looney tune and you know
appears but he's like I say he's smart
because he knows how to adapt over time
like he no longer makes the screaming
let's play as he makes like these
commentary videos and I know he's laying
in hot water a number of times for
various things
mhm but he knows how to like adapt and
like you know that's that's tricky to do
and he's been around for a while too
yeah and he he was one of the people
that I appreciated being really candid
about having like a burnout situation
about feeling like he wasn't fulfilled
with the content that he was making I
appreciate this and I can't imagine the
stress that you have at the level of
subscribers that you have and like all
the eyes on you like you can't ever do
anything completely right at that point
yeah he's very open he's very candid
about that which is kind of refreshing
at that level
yeah for sure is there anyone else that
you're obsessed with yes okay
many people okay there's my goat my
always my first go-to for this question
yeah is a YouTube channel called red
letter media it's just like a group of
dudes just like some you know yeah
middle aged just kind of guys in
Milwaukee okay all they do is review
movies they're so wonderful they're more
they're more of a podcast channel than a
YouTube channel I hate calling them
youtubers cuz they're so goddamn like
they transcend your typical guys they're
not that they review movies and they're
so funny and like they're talked about
dry and sarcastic like you go to these
guys to watch a review of a bad movie
because they are just so articulate in
explaining why a bad movie is bad but
they do it in a fun really funny
entertaining way okay and so I look up
some like every time I upload red letter
media red letter media okay I'm like
their biggest cheerleader another guy
that I really like it well my buddy Eric
hofstadt he does comment etiquette okay
he's a good friend of mine and he
been around I think as long as I have on
YouTube he makes wonderful videos on how
to write comments in the YouTube like in
a video yeah and how it pertains but
like he's so verbose and just the
language he uses it's so funny because
oh so he's great and then another guy
like is video game donkey now he's the
only let's player I watch oh and let's
player means basically you're watching
someone play a video game exactly yeah
and like I like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna sit down and watch a 30 minute
video of a dude playing Red Dead
Redemption or whatever the [ __ ] no I'll
watch this guy because he'll consolidate
all of that into like three minutes okay
and it's like just the hi and it's
almost like it's part notes and it's
almost like a sketch at that point so he
does this really cool combination of
your typical let's play and sketch
comedy and it's as beautiful marriage
and I love it interesting
it seems yeah that seems refreshing and
like I don't know I don't know that
world very well but it doesn't seem like
many people are doing that kind of thing
there no no not at all I mean like there
are some copycats but like he does it
like he's like coke oh okay coca-cola
sorry cacain years what she wants
alternatively yes is there anyone that
you hate follow hate watch I mean you
get we all do it
we all know that we've found people on
Instagram because we can't stand what
they post but you can't look away from
it you don't have to name names
necessarily but I would love for you to
name next has anyone ever named names at
this point I think some people have like
I whoa I look at treasure pages of stuff
all the time okay I'm fascinated by it
yeah fascinating I think she's very
smart and it's fascinating I'll tell you
this here's here so this question when I
will hate watch when drama is stirred so
like when one youtuber I admire or like
says something about another youtuber
like you know look at what this
[ __ ] did of course I go like oh
let's see let's see and that's terrif
like that's bad like I shouldn't that
shouldn't be my knee-jerk reaction
because then that person gets what they
want
yeah fair but I buy into it it also is
your is your community so it's like your
peers captain well you have to know yeah
you got to know like the news what's
going on and you have to know like a bit
of the drama a little bit just you know
so you know what not to do
yeah or you know it's just a figure of
avoid yeah what's a voice early and
sometimes it can be entertaining but
yeah sure I got I got some of those
people that I may watch hate following
yeah do you have anyone that you would
totally fanboy over if you met them in
person that you haven't met yet no I
would not fanboy over have you ever been
for anything yeah yeah hell yeah I
remember when we first met on my music
Jarrett and I were so blown away by your
genuine love for Dave Matthews Band that
sounds like Jack is a Pandora's box cuz
I can't tell I'm learning that he's
sincere about this but I thought it was
a joke
no dude it hasn't changed worship at the
altar of DMB alright he's my boy
III here's I really hate to say this I
listen to his new album he has a new
album a couple months old few months old
okay
and by the way my sister got me into him
years and years ago so we both are like
equally die-hard fan so you're from
Maryland
yeah and so I feel like and I'm from
South Jersey that that was hugely
prevalent when I was in high school
everyone loved Dave Matthews so much
100% yeah that in college too so we both
listened to his new album and keep in
mind we're both diehard fans after which
we both looked at each other and went no
[Laughter]
I mean like but I still love his old
stuff and I'll go to concerts of his
until he dies or I die whatever happens
first yeah and he I think might live
forever
he's one I hope so
I could see it happening okay what
wouldn't you do for Klondike you
supposed to this video where you did
bird box challenge
sure did yeah yeah and then I had to
rename it cuz YouTube was like no no no
no
oh really yeah yeah and I get it so like
so they yeah so YouTube has a cuz it's
dangerous they imposed a blanket ban on
anything bird box challenge related
because dumbasses were actually doing
this like with their kids like parents
were like blindfolding their kids and
their kids were like walking into walls
and [ __ ] it's real by the way like I've
seen the footage to back it up and
[ __ ] disgusting oh no so I wanted to
make fun of the bird box challenge by
pretending like by doing it to my dogs
like I thought I thought the title the
original title was funny enough it was
just like I bird boxed my dog so it's
like I made my dogs do the bird Box
challenge deserve a bet and so I just a
dumb sketch for like I put a blindfold
on Klondike and so I would like I'd
throw a chew toy and then she would
blindly leap after it and then the next
cut would be like a stuffed animal like
launching into a wall that looks like
her videos jump cuts right and it's very
obvious that like no animals were harmed
right youtube d monetize their there I
think it kind of got like shadow band in
the view Department weird and I get it
like it's like I can't complain cause
it's like I know like even parity why
didn't they ban that like Drake Kiki
challenge people were doing that in the
highway [ __ ] they weren't there that's
dangerous
I guess YouTube loves Drake so didn't so
didn't they address no they didn't
address it but I find it funny that in
the YouTube rewind video you saw that
right
Lissie uh no [ __ ] I wasn't invited so I
didn't watch good news no one in our
community was invited yeah no memory I
think told me she's like I watched and I
had to turn it off like 30 seconds it's
very bad I think there's like people
doing a fireside chat circle and feeling
secrets also I just don't I keep up with
pop culture enough to even understand
the references anymore let alone the
people
that are trying to be part of the
references if you want to feel old okay
that's what you watch yeah yeah yeah
right cue it up no but I bring it up
because in the middle of that video so
someone's like it's so organic to hey
let's do that in my feelings challenge
but but it's not the dangerous Karla
it's just like I think it's like dancing
to it like that's how YouTube enter
there like well we have to do a cool
safe family-friendly version so it's
just it's super cringy it's like
animated characters dancing to it
oh it's garbage it's hot flaming garbage
I feel like I was talking to someone
about this when it came out but like it
feels like this past year was like nail
in the coffin of we don't need this and
this cost you guys a lot of money to
make and what if you redistributed that
money into other things and creators and
so what a novel know much about business
I hit record that's why we're used to I
hit record and then I regret it's just
an endless cycle okay well we have a
billion and a half Twitter questions for
you it is so fun to see that people have
some real inquiring minds when I know
some real dumb [ __ ] so we're gonna take
one more quick break and when we get
back we're gonna just [ __ ] dive in
[Music]
- deep deep is brought to you by
Squarespace turn your dream into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project but they're looking to start a
new business showcase your work
published content sell products and more
Squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website all on your own
Squarespace is powerful ecommerce
functionality lets you sell anything
online and analytics help you grow your
site in real time everything is
optimized for mobile right out of the
box and there's nothing to patch or
upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you'll get the help you need with
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support
Squarespace empowers millions of
people's from designers to lawyers
artists to gamers even restaurants and
gyms to turn great ideas into something
real so had the squarespace.com / grace
for a free trial and when you are ready
to launch use the offer code grace to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that squarespace.com /
grace offer code grace okay I'm gonna
ask you the two questions I asked every
single guest that's on the podcast here
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw cold spaghetti at
oh boy I would like to do that to Eric
Andre because I feel like he would do
something funny with that yeah he's one
of my many comedy gods yeah yeah yeah
and I worship his show I think he would
he would do something he would figure
out how to take that situation and
maximize its full comedic potential yeah
oh that's a great one I don't think
we've had that answered yeah yeah no
okay and the other question I ask every
guest is to tell us your worst pants
shooting story or close call you can
only use three words or three small
phrases so mine is college jogging front
lawn friend's basement bathroom I love
when people have an immediate story we
always tell people they're like I
and the shame robot you're a robot okay
now let's get into these Twitter
questions like I said we have so goddamn
many uh someone's no what was your first
impression of Jarrett sleeper when you
worked on my music oh just uh just a
teddy bear of warmth comedy insights he
liked he was so as you know he was so
easy to get along with yes and the whole
thing was I always saw you guys just
like laughing and cracking up and like
he yeah he was just the most confusing
person to me yeah he's a tough nut to
crack because he's just he does
everything you know so much about so
many fields yeah I remember someone
describing it perfectly I think it might
be have been like Lee Newton or
something on the second season that
she's like literally burn the green room
and we look over and Jarrett just has a
book about law that he's studying in the
corner he's now going to law school
apparently like who else does that I
don't know he was always just awesome to
just talk to he was just so warmth yes
you know comes to mind that's great um
so once no do you ever feel like you
could disappoint your fans and fear
losing everything you've gained so far
if so how do you get over that fear of
disappointment hmm I thought you're
gonna say disappoint your family and I
was like I did that years ago no my
family's actually super supportive but
okay so how would I the question is how
would I get over that fear over the fear
of disappointing your fans um just
trying to stay smart like making smart
business decisions that don't backfire
and blow up in my face that's fair yeah
you know you have resolutions do you
make like New Year's resolutions a
little bit yeah there's always like that
last year and this year there's always
like I gotta lose a little weight so
that's like yeah you know I remember you
and like old okay and like a bunch of
other youtubers did this like fitness
challenge what was that shows p90x yes
it was on p90 p90 because they already
did p90x and so Beachbody came to me and
said like we got a new thing out it's
called it's just called p90 and it's a
little simplified version of p90x a
little less extreme
okay still a tonyhorton attached to it
anomic do you want to and I was like
yeah I was at my heaviest and I said
[ __ ] yeah let's do it yeah so so myself
Aaron Olga Bart Baker Brock Baker and
Shira Lazar vo we all did this thing
together and it was uh it was very
strict was three months I mean like that
well they think I'll just like p90x it's
90 days three months yeah we were on a
very strict diet Oh God
yeah but it worked I mean like I lost
almost 30 remember seeing the
before-and-after photos of everyone and
being like holy [ __ ] it's absurd but
like it had to work because it was
extremely strict diet and exercise yeah
it was six days a week workouts and
there were I mean like she's six days a
week yeah yeah and you couldn't and like
we worked with the trainer - some of
those days like we went to a gym to like
make sure we were doing everything right
yeah and like I really can't stress how
strict the diet was like we were on
under like calorie restrictions No
so like that was a big chunk of it
obviously sure I mean and then when you
go in those veins like terms like yeah
if you follow a diet you will lose what
you will okay someone's to know talk
about Jenna we want the tea oh yeah
there's a dog feud yeah yeah we have
this fake rivalry jenna Marbles and I
just with our dogs I I forget how it
started actually but we just the joke is
like we hate each other and our dogs or
we hate each other because of her dogs
you have a better set of dogs and you
think she has a better sense nicely so
we just have fun feuding with that
that's right yeah and people people love
it I think it's gotten to a point where
some people are like oh [ __ ] is this for
real
yeah can I say you seem to have a lot of
fake feuds um when I'm curious to see
when you have a real feud if people
gonna be like he's crying wolf like I
don't believe this and they're gonna
back I need support I don't know if I
have any real feuds I think I'm very
resolute someone's no what's your
favorite and least favorite video that
you've ever released favorite video I
cuz I know this change is probably
I mean it will evolve but yeah I think
we I think a lot of creators we can all
relate to that like we all have
favorites that change over time right
now I'll just hop in my head I'm really
happy with a video I uploaded in 2015
called your grammar sucks 100 because
like your grammar sucks episodes 1
through 99 we're just like a little
five-minute videos or SQL things and
then I really wanted to go big for 100
so I ended up making a feature-length
long like 60 minute long right yeah and
I worked it took me a whole year to do
it because it's like 60 plus youtubers
yeah you know including you and
everyone's in it everyone's in it
basically YouTube rewind it was that's
right
without all of those in my feelings
challenges yeah and it was sketches
after like it was doesn't literally
dozens of sketches there were multiple
different segments like a little like
recurring bits and there was a like I
wrote like seven original songs it's
like almost the musical like I went
balls out for this video and I think
it's I'm proudest of it I don't go back
and watch it because I mean like it's
it's an hour-long youtube video they're
they're tricky to actually sit and watch
through but I'm really happy that I did
it it's there yeah no it's just it's
this body of work I'm very very proud of
that's awesome
do you have any of those sort of
grandiose or ideas for this year you
have to give us the details cuz if it's
still stewing in your brain well I was
really inspired by Bandersnatch on
Netflix did you see that no I haven't
for those who aren't aware it's just
it's a choose-your-own-adventure
on Netflix and it works flawlessly very
clever I think it's I think was executed
very well a lot of people have some
criticisms with like the storytelling I
think it's just a brilliant idea done
well and I wasn't I was inspired by that
and I know that choose your own
adventures is no original concept on
YouTube people have been doing that
since the start but I want to do
something clever with that I want to
make a quiz and I'll just say I don't
care yeah I want to do a are you
familiar with the YouTube channel
WatchMojo I've heard of it I've never
seen it they do top 10 lists and
countdowns every day yeah yeah 5 a day
and like they've done two big ones like
the top 10
best action scenes or the top 10 worst
this best that okay but they've been
around for so long that they've done
every conceivable top 10 list you can
think of and now they're fit like the
last year couple of years it's just like
bottom of the barrel stuff it's like top
10 actors who he didn't know we're vegan
so I want to make a quiz uh-huh
where well I want to do I want to take
the Bandersnatch approach where it's
like choose your answer and then that
answer will fork over a fork out into
like you're right or you're wrong or
whatever but the quiz it's multiple
choice and it's out of these four titles
which is a fake WatchMojo thing or which
one is the real one in a you know in a
sea of four answers so I want to like
make a quiz out of that oh that's
interesting that would involve making
like 40 50 videos because if for each
answer I have to put in a nope you're on
try again you know like for though I
don't even do this it's not doable
I just set aside like a week well I
think that's fascinating and I hope that
anyone listening or watching this
podcast spams you to get that done I
think it's what the world needs
thank you what the world needs what's
your favorite kids pop album well how do
I choose they're all so good it's like
choosing my favorite dog which a lot of
these questions are asking that oh good
oh no kids pop 15 was really when it
came into its own I like to say now I
got a long running thing with it that's
another inside joke I make fun of Kidz
Bop all the time because like well that
was the thing I made the kids pop quiz
so I had Seabury Nikki limo over and we
made a quiz out of it we're like I love
doing I have so much fun writing the
quiz I would give them a a song lyric
like a jet like a real song they're from
an original pop song and I was like okay
and it was like a little risque okay so
I would say okay no how did Kidz Bop
repurpose this yes there's multiple
choice there's one two three or four and
it was really it turns out the quiz was
super [ __ ] hard yeah
so it was Aaron Steve and Nikki were all
playing against each other and like that
like there were 15 questions and no one
had a score higher than I don't remember
what the high score was but it was
really [ __ ] hard and I'm super proud
because I can write like a Kidz Bop
writer you know but yeah that's what so
ever since then even before then that's
that's what the whole Kidz Bop thing is
about I love it I also think Kidz Bop is
really weird when you really think it's
someone's job to repurpose those lyrics
and then hire children to sing them I
don't it's a little bit like we've
talked in the packets for about zoom did
you run zoom growing up on like PBS it's
like the science show that had all the
kids yes yes yes I always wanted to be
on that show yeah I think I was based on
a boss and so I think it was a very East
Coast kind of scenario maybe if there's
like a Netflix reboot you could be the
host yeah that's all I want to be a my
yeah someone's you know do you've any
advice for those who have trouble with
public speaking any yeah genuine advice
I mean like I judge first off you should
not come to a guy like me for advice
like that do you do live shows yeah yeah
I do yeah like on Twitch and never like
in person like at theaters and stuff
like that I've done that too yeah a
little bit of that and I mean practice
that's the only way you get good at
something yeah the only way you get
confident more confident of being a
youtuber a good youtuber is just keeping
practice and doing it you just shoot in
front of a camera film yourself it's
gonna first time you turn on that camera
and you talk into it it's awkward as
[ __ ] hell yeah I hated it yeah but
you know I when you make a thousand
videos it you're gonna get good at it
you're gonna get into a rhythm do you
edit all your videos - have you ever
thought about hiring an editor or is
that like a control issue thing the
latter a control issue thing and I've
had in the past I've had just like a
couple of videos edited by editors just
like but it's really it's really tricky
so like for example a formulaic video or
series like yeah or Jack asked yes
that's what I passed off not not every
time like it's only like once every
like 20 or 30 but I will pass that off
to an editor just to make it faster but
for a comedy sketch how do you do that
how do you an hi especially cuz you know
like for company stuff it's all in your
head you like you have a very specific
vision right and you don't want anyone
touching that and also comedy is on the
tour at least my kind of comedy is all
in the timing
yeah which means a very precise
frame-by-frame editing yeah and when
you're shooting 60 frames a second it's
such a [ __ ] Shore like you know
picking the right frame to cut something
yeah I have to do that I don't trust
another editor to do that
that's so fair how long on average does
it take you to edit a video it depends
on which one I'm sure anywhere from a
couple of hours to like a few days I
just suppose so going up at like 12 it's
like yeah a few minutes huh I'm
uploading a video called one second of
every video I made in 2018 whoa a little
yes it's a cute little highlight reel
uh-huh so I made like a hundred 20
videos last year Jesus so that takes a
long time it's like it's not just
getting all the videos together but it's
choosing the right mm-hmm
second that encapsulate s-- like is that
a [ __ ] washer okay get the whole like
that captures the idea of the video it's
almost because you were you a music
major so I was a film major music minor
okay and it feels like that's like
composing a song almost like that's
exactly it yeah there's a lot yes
I've talked about that before was like
an old professor but like yeah cuz I had
a when I was in college one of the film
courses I took was taught by a guy who
like used to write hit songs in the 8th
or like he had like a couple of little
micro hits ladies and he often compared
editing a video or a film to writing a
song because we note like when we watch
a movie yeah it's not even like a
YouTube video but a movie we know we
just kind of instinctively know that
there should be this rhythm of cuts yeah
and if a camera lingers too long on
something like a conversation between
two people yeah there's got to be that
rhythm of the back and forth you know of
the 180 rule and blah blah blah there
has to be that that rhythm yeah and I
think it does help if you have some
background in music to edit a video or
film that makes sense
that makes sense you just got a Ted
guys Congrats Congrats so many people
we're coming near the end of the podcast
but so many people want to know what's
happening for you in 2019 like what can
people look out for I'm trying to get
weird and experimental well and what
does that mean so I'm trying it I want
to try different things on and off
YouTube yeah are you do you look into
like the traditional world like TV film
stuff at all a little bit like I want to
try pitching a series like make it first
yeah but yeah I do that a little bit
here's the thing I don't do auditions
cuz yeah I'd like I don't I don't do any
of that
cuz I want to create more than like acts
yeah well first off I'm a sucky actor
but I would much rather create turn to
was a legend no no no none of us knew
what the [ __ ] we were doing
I'll just screaming into the void but to
answer your questions like not so much
traditional media like that but I want
to like create more thing like I want to
make a game you know I want to take it's
cool it's like one of my series and turn
it into like an actual downloadable game
that will be awesome
that's what I'm working on one of the
things I'm working on in 2019 and like I
said that choose-your-own-adventure
thing like I want to get weird and
experimental on YouTube like that cool
and some other things too
it's just fun I just want to try I just
kind of want to widen my pool yeah no
that makes sense it was like it's the
right time no one knows what what we're
all doing on YouTube so it's like why
not experiment why not throw new
spaghetti at a wall and see what happens
and spaghetti comes back as circular I
love that Jack where can people find you
if they don't already know you can find
me on youtube at youtube.com slash
Jack's films or you can find me on
Twitter at Jack's films very cool and um
because you are made time for us on the
podcast we give everyone that is a guest
a personalized fortune cookie that
you're welcome to open personalized
fortune cookie yeah let's see all right
I don't think let's see it's a break-in
to go all right don't worry there
no [ __ ] yeah says oh no feces on camera
Twitter for Android which how do you
describe this shenanigan to people
because you are on a speaking of what's
up for you in 2019 you're on a [ __ ]
mission right now oh my god it was so
stupid so I do this thing every day
since January first and we're only into
like right now we're currently at the
recording of this podcast were in late
January yeah but every day I tweet
Twitter for Android but the catch is
it's not just that
because that would be lazy i screen grab
like the previous day's tweet mhm and
then also tweet on top of it Twitter for
Android and so it just stretches out
into this long blurry pixelated
disgustingly cropped message yeah and I
want to see if I can do it for everyday
in 2019 see your number 365 days yeah
we're not even through the first month
of the year and it's already incredibly
stressful to look at thank you for
making time and doing this and being
here I'm so excited to see how all these
like creative cool ideas come to
fruition or not you know how fickle we
youtubers are thanks for having me this
is awesome of course guys go check out
Jack's films if you haven't already and
we'll see you next time on not too deep
goodbye too deep too deep go deep not
too deep with grace Helbig
[Music]